Oh what's up everybody should boil and
fresh I'm here with MSX by Michael
Strahan and my guy making Fitzpatrick
we're here in Miami Florida we're gonna
talk fashion we're gonna pick out an
outfit and we're gonna go to the jungle
and play with the animals like this come
and look are breathable come jog nice
and light the Miami Heat
if you get a little hot you got t-shirt
on this is dodo and make it cool later
so all right so how you feel man I feel
good got a nice fit on the ms6 fit on
constable live for the day so uh let's
talk about your your love for style like
when did that start for you oh I mean
that's like looking nice where there be
the comfortable clothing or just up my
suit as is like just being comfortable
but also recognized at the same time so
you got your fit you're looking good you
think you're gonna make it today in
Miami but then you go survive welcome to
Jungle Island just trust me and I
promise you'll leave with everything
intact we're gonna jump right in we're
gonna do one of the craziest things
first
this is Darnell's area Darnell is one of
our largest and most aggressive
alligators you're totally safe we know
what we're doing how you know she not
right dude that's why we're going in
first
I know you guys are both strong large
men but she will overpower you in an
instant now to make you feel safer I'm
gonna be holding on to you while you're
doing it okay okay you first
we gotta go down there I can't just stay
up here I openly insert here perfect now
we're gonna go meet the Penguins oh no
he likes you you would know it if they
didn't like you come on boys
good boys so Minka do you remember the
grapes you have in your bag yeah I got
him the head alright cuz we're gonna
feed them to these little guys okay
[Music]
so these are the red kangaroos from
Australia
[Music]
all right let's go
[Music]
not gonna like flip out on us er I mean
I don't think so it's an animal we're
like in the middle of it so I want to
make sure that you know this and we all
know like he says guys I'm gonna take
you into the lemur room they stink and
they scream really loud come on in hi
guys what was your favorite part I was
really nervous by that a good as I was
fooling actually actually doing that was
a fun day in Miami thanks for having me
sir oh my god
[Music]